Ciao Carmela Che bello vederti Non
vedevo l'ora io io so benissimo ma tu
piuttosto ti vedo
ringiovanita Vabbè che tu sei sempre
bella eh tuo figlio è un amore
d'altronde la mela non cade mai troppo
lontano dall'albero No Pensa che mi
aiuta sempre con lavori mi fa le
lavatrici mi fanno lo so sono lavori che
spettano a me Ci mancherebbe si offri
dicono no amore stai sul divano riposati
che tu sei un uomo hai bisogno di
riposare quest'anno è partito proprio
bene Ho deciso di eliminare tutte le
persone tossiche della mia vita che non
ce ne sono neanche tante in realtà è
solo una che proprio non mi fa piacere
vedere però purtroppo mi tocca Sì sì sì
al lavoro Ovvio hai visto eh il
maglioncino che mi ha regalato a Natale
No guarda Carmela un acrilico
morbidissimo ti devo ringraziare lo
metto tutti i giorni Vabbè ora vado che
devo fare le pulizie a casa lo sai che
sono fissata mi piace proprio fare le
pulizie mi si riempie il cuore di gioia
Carmela succede anche a te e niente
allora spero di vederti prestissimo Ho
fatto piacere